un tigre en liberté au milieu des
enfants
bien sûr les bambins sont ravis et les
parents rassurés les animaux
n'apparaissent que sur les téléphones
portables ou les tablettes dans ce parc
de montauban 12 panneaux jalonnent les
pelouse
il suffit d'utiliser une application sur
son smartphone pour voir les animaux
sauvages
alors en fait quand je vais filmer le
totem le zèbre il arriva ouais voilà
l'effet du zèbre sur le pont là est très
bien rendu donc je trouve
qu'effectivement on est vraiment dans la
réalité augmentée ce pirate qui salue
est né dans cette start up à montauban
dans ses bureaux
les graphistes et les informaticiens
imagine des personnages et des
animations
par exemple c'est le pirate donc on
commence par trouver la tête qui nous
plaît là donc là c'est l'étape d'après
on a déjà trouvé une tête et on fait des
expressions on a eu la modélisation en
3d on a eu le travail des textures de
couleurs et l'animation
donc voilà tout c'est toutes ces étapes
avant de l'intégrer dans ce logiciel
pour l'envoyer on va dire vers
l'application la réalité augmentée c'est
filmé avec son téléphone par exemple ce
tapis de souris
l'application développée par la start up
se charge alors de rajouter des
personnages sur ce que l'on voit c'est à
dire d'augmenter la réalité l'animation
démarre lorsque le téléphone reconnaît
une image bien précise sur un set de
table un gobelet ou sur cette assiette
en carton
aujourd'hui la réalité augmentée elle
est utilisée par beaucoup de sociétés
surtout pour de l'événementiel ou du
marketing nous on est vraiment les
premiers à travailler avec des
industriels pour faire des produits de
grande consommation
on ne peut dire prenez leaders mondiaux
aujourd'hui dans les décorations de
pâtissière interactive et sur la
vaisselle jetable interactive puisqu'on
est à peu près les seuls à faire ce type
de produit de manière industrielle est
distribué dans la grande distribution
magic expérience vient de s'implanter
aux états unis et prévoit de multiplier
son chiffre d'affaires par dix avec près
de 80% de ses ventes réalisées outre
atlantique bien sûr la réalité augmentée
ça n'est pas que pour les enfants les
applications sont immenses
par exemple visiter une ville où essayer
une paire de lunettes sur internet ou
encore changer une pièce dans un moteur
est évidemment nos reportages pourrait
aussi être différent sans trucage l'idée